Food does define people and it has defined Chinese people in Britain.
And I think I feel for the British people because I think you've had that same definition:...
...British people, British food; not so good...
...you know, so I think times have changed very much so.
My father was very entrepreneurial and he moved our family from Taiwan to South Africa when I was five.
And then when I was about ten in December 1988,...
...he moved us here to England.
It was a big shock to the system.
Coming from very sunny, open spaced South Africa...
...to London which was at that time not the best time to come in December: dull, miserable, grey.
The food that I had; my first experience at school was having jacket potatoes, fish and chips,...
...pies and a lot of it was fine for the first week.
But week after week after week, it was the same set of food...
...so for me, it was very, very bland and very boring.
So I was coming back from university one day,...
...and I was really hungry and I stopped off at the usual suspects.
And I saw an array of oriental packets like salads and dishes and I thought, "Oh, this is new."
"This is something very interesting and different."
So they're obviously trying to up their game...
...and I took my first bite and I was so disappointed.
It was the most boring, bland noodle salad I'd ever tasted.
And I thought to myself, "I could do better than this."
And that was when it gave me an idea to start my own business.